salut tout le monde si vous voulez louer
le studio sf pour faire votre propre
podcasts ou pour objet d la qualité de
votre podcast c'est possible écrivez
nous à sans filtre podcast at gmail.com
vous venez ici le service et tout
compris vous avez la vidéo vous avez le
son qu'on vous donne suite après votre
enregistrement
yann nicol qui va être là pour vous
servir pour vous accompagner dans cette
aventure
le studio sf on s'assure que la qualité
est optimale à tous les niveaux et puis
pour ramener votre projet au niveau
c'est vraiment la bonne chose à faire
alors écrivez-nous savoir plaisir de
vous recevoir ici une production du f
[Musique]
bienvenue sans fil dans le podcast où on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
date si tu cherches quentin
habituellement avec moi doom plantes
paulo pour l'instant cette semaine sur
le sans filtre on a fait un deux parties
si c'est à dire que ce que vous écoutez
en ce moment sur la première partie de
notre entretien avec kevin raphaël et on
a continué sur son propre média ça lui
qui s'appelle sans restriction donc si
vous aimez ce que vous entendez en ce
moment où pas nécessairement en ce
moment mais dans l'approché nord vous
irez considère conversation sur son
podcast à lui ou keven se transforme en
interviewer qu'elle vendra fels et qui
vous vous demandez si vous ne savez pas
déjà qu'ils vendent raphaël c'est un
journaliste sportif sportif pardon un
animateur un humoriste un gars
extrêmement craquer de la vie on a parlé
entre autres
c'était quelque chose que l'on voulait
absolument board avec heaven dieu blake
lively madère particulièrement dans le
sport donc essayer de voir comment les
grandes ligues du monde ont réussi à
intégrer le mouvement justice sociale à
l'intérieur de leur retour à la
compétition poste qu'ovide on ne parlait
plus largement du black l'armada
évidemment on a qu'evans n'est pas mâché
ses mots par rapport à l'hymne national
les mêmes pensées l'année cela la rocqué
pardon j'ai même pensé ne pas écouter
les séries le matois cette année en
guise de protestation contre le
le manque d'action l'inaction de lineage
est vraiment un point de vue super
intéressant de parler de la classique
heaven raphaël qui vient tout juste
d'avoir lieu qu'un contenu de la
discussion avec heaven c'était avant la
classique mais la scène a eu lieu salle
eu l'air d'avoir été un franc succès
donc on parle de ceux et ensuite si vous
voulez à l'écouté la sur la compensation
comme juste à l'heure qui vient de se
transformer en interviewer et on a parlé
de natation n'a parlé de notre passé
d'athlète depuis mois on ne parlait des
olympiques on a monté notre relais de
rêve vraiment une conversation plus en
plus axée sur le sport parce que c'est
le concept de son podcast
sinon suivez nous sur peut tuer en après
chaque pas de casse on essaie de faire
un avec moins de filtres ou encore moins
de filtres ou est ce qu on fait juste
parler de la conversation convient
d'avoir en long en large à chaud après
les podcasts ou un petit peu plus tard
dans la semaine qui en connaît pas le
temps de la tournée du sud après parce
que le studio commence à être assez
bouquet fait que c'est ça dans le fond
et écouter écrire des commentaires
ce que vous avez pensé de la
conversation laqué partager partager
fait tout ce que vous savez qu'on
demande à chaque semaine parce que ça
fait son boulot même ça nous aide
grandement
mais avant tout et ça c'est toujours le
plus important
bonne écoute et bon podcast
[Musique]
y'a cei merci mène aux autres bruits yes
je comptais gérable je ride terrain non
mais j'ai vu les sansfil jeudi un moment
donné les partenaires vont m'appeler
j'ai dit je vais laisser mon téléphone
nouvelles puis les gars moi ça a pris
deux ans mais je m'applique à vii redis
c'est encore mieux
ben oui selon vous êtes gros dans une
courbe et merci merci je ne sais pas si
tu te rappelles la première fois qu'on
s'est rencontrés pour vrai c'était à
l'événement de patrice bernier blood 2
oui je me rappelle je m'appelle geller
moi j'avais
ça tournait vite dans ce temps là dans
ma ville mais ni d'eau des semaines
quelques mois exact exact j'avais fait
une piètre performance n'est pas mauvais
c'était juste pas bon exact j'aurais
moi-même un patin on a passé beaucoup de
temps à natation le dos et dans le
concret la natation puis la coordination
mon dieu à mes yeux ça jamais été le
huawei jamais le sort que ses hommes de
résident
un espoir qui coûte le moins cher
affaire qui semble être le plus facile à
apprendre mais ces fortunes difficile le
sens où il courait pour rien après ça
leurs noms étaient petites joies et nos
mains le témoin c'était pied de port à
utiliser tes mains l'a déjà notre
problème est bien là précieux ya dix
autres joueurs si le terrain fait là ça
c'est dans ton équipe labs à notre idée
bien à 11h12 c'est compliqué explique
mois circule je joue à patrice ses amis
ouais bah sinon jupons c'est ça qui je
pensais que c'était tout un événement si
tu sais quand la classique si ce ne
serait pas moi je serai meilleur que moi
j'ai joué au hockey maintenant six ans
jusqu'à bantam de ses meilleurs bon
maintenant je dois être
je dois t'adapter près du niveau d -g
donc non atteint face à ce que tu dis
parce que jay et douaniers m veepee non
mais maintenant c'est parce que je pense
que je garde ça pis y'a des gars qui
jouent à la glace et qui ont joué son
genre est vrai que c'est jay et son
apport au niveau junior majeur au québec
on voit la première fois j'ai vu j'ai
joué là bas et il y avait un groupe de
gaulle qui joue propiété comme mieux
c'est qu'elle parte mais les cheveux
longs sets j'ai dit a fait la première
année il se garde une gêne pour la
deuxième année au salon prend même pas
c'est à dire la deuxième année j'ai fait
4 6 3
mais pour la guerre c'est du bon regarde
regarde pendant que je rentrais dans le
building ya quelqu'un qui s'est désisté
sauf si tu veux jouer je n'ai pas dis à
personne encore il ya un spot et que si
tu veux jouer
c'est une séquence à celle qui résout 15
août c'est un samedi 13h si tu veux
jouer chaque déjà fan je veux jouer et
un spot qu'émane que je t'écris après le
patient je regarde mes six vols ccns les
deux premières périodes ouais après sa
troisième c'est pas n'importe quoi même
en effet les joueurs pros deviennent
foules sont hyper compétitif c'est la
razzia de troisième période les tchèques
les cowboys pelé veulent pas perdre sa
glace voilà il ya le jour et la nuit
c'est ce qu'il pensait beaucoup de
vagues tombe c'est marc mais c'est une
belle eva ici je reprends cette année
cette année on a vu que les gars jouent
à elle maintenant la bulle on peut pas
avoir autant de jours la nature
l'étendue bois bobigny nous sommes en a
des bons joueurs placés ont des bons
joueurs
cette année on a vu les no de confirmer
d'ucla de confirmer on essaie de
convaincre anthony mantha nicolas
deslauriers fait tout les jours des
équipes élites et joue mais cette année
ce qu'on trouve vraiment mais ce qu'on
peut enfin mettre la lumière sur la
cuisine un mois j'étais un gros gars
d'ath et féminin on va avoir plus de
joueurs qui ont peu de ligue en ce
moment festif c'est vraiment vraiment
naïf mais je suis quand même content
d'avoir plein jour c'est comme ma grosse
fierté c'est le fun 2 à 4 200 personnes
à l'aréna cause du col v d'honoraires
d'avoir plus respectés savage a intimé
pas et team parce que l'aréna c'est 3500
places mais va voir 202 dans la sphère
les mouvements vers les sports
professionnels féminins il ya vraiment
de plus en plus gros mondiale manche et
que la nba font un effort soit un énorme
pour une région peu le spotlight par la
wnba puis ça je trouve ça vraiment cool
quand même
j'ai dépensé 400 pièces dans le store de
bio mbiye deux semaines parce que
j'écoutais ma maman joueuse mon athlète
préféré en ce moment à ce moment c'est
megan rapinoe la joueuse de soccer
je trouve qu'il est vraiment importante
pour la société vraiment importante
qu'est ce qu'a fait pierre tielemans
puis ma deuxième c'est sabrina younès
cook joue dans la de bio en billets je
pense que se blesser j'ai presque plus
horrible quand j'ai presque plus jeudi
mais non mais nafie a train de redéfinir
le sport féminin puis à un plus de quoi
débattre mais non parce que je trouve
que bon matelas qui fut menée par
exemple les faits puis je sais pas si
les gens et sable mais les filles
faisaient 2000 places par aline à
l'autre les 2000 places la ccsa payer
150 et payer l'équipement s'étaient
quittés au niveau de nationale 2 mille
pièces par année pour les filles
ben ali contraint d'entrer dans ces
genres sans entrer dans les nachos et
850 me reste c'est pour les blancs qui
prétend le contraire minimum
tout est à 125 et vous trouvez tout
héroïsme et autres jouets
ne tentez poche nasl mais tu fais
beaucoup d'argent ça c'est fait leur
permettant que tes poches à laval c'est
un bon joueur de hockey et c'était des
joueurs qui jouent pour team canada pour
team us et des machines que dans leur
l'équipe a avec team canada où tu es
mieux c'est parce que je pense que notre
organisation team canada prend bien soin
de nos joueuses de ce que je comprends
je pense que tu me vois c'est aussi le
font encore mieux avec les américaines
mais il était payé 2000 pièces la route
fou tu manges tu mêles de déplacement
l'aréna foutu paix qu est ton équipement
foutu paye mais d'autres coachs ou prou
combien de bâton dans le kit se passe
par années 3,4 foot appelle un 3 4 3 4
quand tu fais attention attention la
pelouse ont tout juste part at on fait à
temps mais attention pas attention 4 5 6
et tant de médias c'est parti ça coûte
250 pièces par ce texte à main levée
rouge plusieurs fois l'ol sur ip pour
jour 1c les professionnels si ça
comptait payer pour ton entraîneur privé
pas faire le mal qu'ils font juste pas
parce qu'il ya un mec qui peuvent pas se
le permettre
la calcul qui ont un autre qui ont une
odeur la méthode ce n'est pas 8 à 5
le fou du printemps char tu t'en ailles
à laval dans le trafic
arrivé pour la pratique tu fais ta
pratique protat 12 se retourne chez vous
l'ayez onze ark est surtout ne te
coucher ton travail et makes no sense
qu'est ce qui se passe avec le hockey
féminin puis là je sais que les filles
travaillent fort ayant bâti lapidot by
which pillés c'est l'association des
joueuses de hockey féminin effet
travaille fort ils veulent bâtir quelque
chose mais ge comme johann tschopp vous
êtes ou quand guys un moment de nine et
puis t il ya plusieurs choses que je
peux pas tout dire maintenant mais que
make you know and cher son décès
d'épicés shit dans ces cités dans ce
dossier la petite île les formes étant
de faire de faire un match d'exhibition
femme avant les séries
c'est comme la fal you nous on est black
line 2 il à voix haute
on va pas de l'écrire sur le la glace
sur les bords ne vaut pas le maître ne
le parle on va jamais dire black eyed
peas mado on va jamais l'écrire nulle
part mais au supporter la cause mais
n'ont cessé de faire à moitié
combien de propriétaires seraient
capables d'avoir une autre qui fut menée
chez elle tout le monde tout le monde
sous des milliards dans ses environs 1.2
millions par année pour faire vivre une
équipe droit en phase 6 est et pourquoi
pourquoi ne pas de ligue 1 le débat est
plus juste
ils font 2000 par année ils font le
débat c'est pourquoi la ligue nationale
riposta fallait live je sais je sais que
bon aux états unis il ya eu une autre
ligue de hockey féminin qui sait comme
le hisse kosslick du rock féminin mais
la ligue et encore le zoo quitté antique
il ya beaucoup de choses chéri qui se
passe là bas sur ce que toutes les
meilleures joueuses veulent pas les
leurs ils veulent se bâtir leur affaire
mais la ligue nationale et plus la ligne
orange veut pas favoriser un ou l'autre
parce que c'est d'épicés chip fait la
moyenne nationale il y en a un site à
ligue professionnelle
l'autre c'est ton east coast league
notre tout le monde joue tout le monde
est payé minimum trente mille îles ouest
tout ce qu'ils demandent
imagine les demandes 30min ouest parer
aux effets m'imagine j'ai toujours du
seul quand j'ai fini ma 40 ans georges
esi j'aurais continué mais ton tu
m'aurais donné trente mille pièces là
j'aurais continué pour 30000 pierre
j'aurais continué à faire la natation
professionnels aussi longtemps qu'ils
m'auraient donné sur les eaux selon time
encore après pas abandonner aussi
contacter murray de donner ce jeu pour
m'entraîner plus faire un sport que
j'aime c'est tout ce que je demandais
les foules nous un petit peu je senti un
petit change pour manger imaginons de
talent qui ont jamais été développée à
cause qui a mené si si c'est trop dur
c'est ceux-là moi j'ai une de mes bonnes
amies qui je parlais avec el pais a
indiqué je pense je vais pas jouer stan
mais tellement bonne tu vas pas joué
cette année y'a mais faut que je me
concentre sur mon affaire de tes
rapports sportifs de thérapeute sportif
parce que je peux je peux pas manger
sinon satisfait comme houston dans la
ligue bas qu'ils ne décomptent y en
avait une féminine la fille après le
projet parce que foccart manche mx
non-sense pis si je trouve que les
médias parlent jamais si c'est pour moi
qui en parlera pas le port
bref comme et c'est pas juste que jan
leysen épique qu'il faut parler de ses
fils maintenant si je parle de hockey
féminin ce moment parce que c'est comme
mon gros et à mon gros cambodge avec les
filles je les aime beaucoup
non juste pour les basques beau film sur
le sac féminin était sur sa restriction
d'instagram on met beaucoup de trucs de
circuit féminin
là les gens commencent à poser des
questions les gens font mouche et et
quoi aussi ceux qui aiment le basket
dans un sondage autrefois que j'ai dit
est ce que vous êtes tannés commet des
choses des deux bios nba c'était parce
que ça 4,56 comme dans les câbles je
sais c'est d'apprendre une nouvelle
rafale soit parce que si tout ce que tu
veux c'est la nba où la haine est celle
où house ou n'importe quel sport
masculin
tu en as déjà c'est partout c'était
perdre et perdre ainsi tu prends locke
et féminins selon moi il est plus beau
que l'acquis masculin parce que là qui
fut donné ça fera moins eu plus de place
plus de beau jeu à la base la criminelle
et plus nice de lacq et masculin à mes
yeux dans une mer
adidas bat là je suis pas quand j'étais
petit voir scott stevens était tout le
monde j'étais dans le coup mais rendue à
l'âge où je suis il après avoir eu au
top cow boys you je suis comme plus à
l'aise de voir des gosses fait pleuvoir
des commotions noir est-ce que quatre
soit york et féminin les filles sont et
font des bons jeux font des belles
passes pitié pour la classe et qu'on
pratique avec une coupe défi qui ça me
fait rigoler brésilienne jouer les
pyromanes et des filles jeunes praj frau
a appelé classique à l'année passée
parce qu'on avait mergerac américaine
qui m'amène s'agira que j'aime beaucoup
ça m'amène je laime d'amorcer m'amène
49,2 colorado et le nasdaq vers la
gauche puis moi j'ai dit ailleurs salut
voila pop tchèque c'est fini le relais
des bonnes mais ce jeudi sa meilleure
forme a démarré face à la li ion à la
flip la rondelle par dessus de bateaux
de sam d'allopass au travail ce jeudi au
tout le monde s'est levé dans l'arène
les ovations debout
allopass carrier mais c'est juste les
bosses que ça a pris pour faire ça à lui
à la place à un humoriste
elle a pris bonne humeur joie qui est à
la paix à la digue être montrée mois
puis je sais que ça ne trouviez beaucoup
de respect pour s'appuie tout le monde
peut la voir
tapez sur le casque comme youtube et le
gothique auprès non c'est toi même s'il
se cacherait pas poche mais franchement
je mets en place le pass que ce match
est le plus important ça avoir du fun on
a du fun ii qu'on arrive à la reine
résultats le maire masse dans la chambre
est ce que tout le monde n'y as tout le
monde s'est fait des blagues tout le
monde ces petites classes on prend mange
mad les délits au phoque lui les y ont
volé mais pas tué l'année passée et on
va les départs volés mais pas telle
année prison cachée dans leur chambre
sur cinq minutes avant la classique j'ai
pas de patin dans les pieds du monde du
caillou habitants
combien j'ai cette pêche pas j'oublie
mes patins chez nous moi je m'en allais
retourner chez nous
le fim a maquillé caveau des patriarches
mallet retourner chez nous là
mon match d alpha mais c'est loin cachée
mais pas telle chaque radio j'ai besoin
de mes pattes et une belle ambiance sur
la glace iphone
le tir de barrage à tout le monde en
tirs de barrage chaque période qui s'est
fois qu'il n'en est pas ce que tout le
monde est créatif l'outil le premier
ravi tout le monde était comme gêné les
amène aussi le le monde a encore laissé
troisième c'est entre les deux entre la
première et la deuxième entre la
deuxième et la troisième c'est la 3ème à
la 5ème et 6ème et 5ème puis les butins
chaudardes compte puis le seul règlement
ce qui en a pas ce la rondelle passe la
ligne rouge c'est un but faict peut
reculer se veut dire tu peux bouger le
bus rouge
moi j'ai vu un rafale ss en breton je
pensais pas qu'ils y ont amené toute
l'équipe at toute l'équipe adverse sur
la glace puis on fait un décret pris
entre les jambes de la fil avait en
moyenne guys fait qu'hydro cycliques
commencent à être créatifs commence à
penser à lille parce qu'ils savent que
ça quand le but qu'on s'est dit que le
trophée la célébration casquette de
champion champagne d'achat 6 et ce en un
vrai match c'est là c'est la coupe
stanley je gagnerai jamais c'est comme
ça je l'appelle c'est la coupe stanley
chez les artistes devront appliquer une
coupe de la ligue nationale quand grand
jamais rangé ce qui c bobbi l'équipe m'a
dit moi qui avais jamais rien gagné dans
ma ville la casquette de chanteur et
chinois basés sur nos temps forts le
nombre de personnes qui est qui ont
investi leur carrière ça n'a jamais rien
gagné
ben oui tout à fait à faible c'est fou
comment maintenant cesser ces ultras
valoriser ce mettons le championship vie
c'est la chose la plus valorisée le
génie je regardais je dis bien probable
textures et métiers a attirés par la nba
le l'équipe de commandes chaque chat cas
d'un avec avec chuck charles barkley ya
il ya eu cette chance bâclé c'est
considéré comme le meilleur joueur un
des meilleurs joueurs à avoir jamais
rien gagné puis chaque et l'appui comme
à chaque fois qu'ils ont eu des boks
sont les deux pandas tel chèque
l'arrière puis faire assez drôle que tu
dis ça parce que moi j'ai deux
championnats de la nba puis j'ai de mvp
de la finale
pis toi dans nos ports jamais rien gagné
ce sera peut-être populace que je dis
moi je suis bien d'accord
césar nasa pensait aussi si tu es le
meilleur ton équipe
pittis considéré comme un des meilleurs
au monde t'es pas cap économique des
vétilles dans le championship économique
david est un échec
si lebron james gagnait pas minimum 3
minimum oui on ne demande pas un luxe et
ronny ron reagan expérience fut un échec
parce que tu es tellement bon que je
peux pas comprendre que tu gagnes pas si
tu gagnes pas parce qu'il ya d'autres
choses à l'extérieur qui font en sorte
que tout bangkok y en a qui essaient
pour ceux qui n'ont pas gagné si on te
demande pas de deux failles 800 peu la
télévision ou de ta job c'est toujours
basket toujours soccer ou du rock et si
tu gagnes pas mais qu'il te plaît de
d'activité externe mais je vais challen
c'est peut-être pour ça ce petit jeu le
challenge serrer des mains des passeurs
de la ligue par des chutes en ce moment
ouais mais posh commencé mais parce que
d'autres ou d'activités j'encourage les
extraits cultes extra curriculum je les
encourage tout le temps les joueurs à se
développer des talents parce que quand
la retraite arrive après celle du 1er
mai
deux développeurs développera le talent
quand elle a fait les play-offs
outtara moutons équipes ostende les
coptes j'ai fait beaucoup de compatit de
compassion de patience avec des gens qui
sont payés des millions $ ni que ils
trouvent ça tough pour pouvoir faire le
party moi le vrai j'ai vraiment pas
beaucoup de compassion et que ces gens
là dernièrement la nba c'est solange une
bulle baby loup il ya le titre i quit la
pub pour aller at and family man cbc les
funérailles de son droit c'est à fait
clair il sort le temps là il se fait
dire par tout le monde fait attention
genre prend toutes les mesures pour
avoir besoin de faire le pire qu'on veut
c'est la quarantaine en finale s'est
faite là il se fait prendre même dans un
club de danseuses plaisir mais j'allais
je cherchais des ailes de poulet
c'est un domaine des pays des millions
de dollars poursuit tu peux pas la merde
sur de la glace pendant même chepan à
quatre mois tébéo millions de dollars
pour ce qui met en jeu
tout le monde sait les meilleurs vins de
lumière d'alep ceux qui disent c'est pas
de sel ou et le poulet non seulement ça
c'est que la cup la photo de lui avec
dans ce club
la pression dignité la photo mais tout
le monde a dit bien que c'est toi après
a dit non c'est pas moins mais n'avons
il y avait le masque qui ont donné dans
la buse y avait le masque la nba qui
s'étaient donnés dans deux ans il est 17
x men jungle non mais parce que lou
williams est un sujet particulier mais
aussi pour sa première passe en premier
s'il met mais en même temps je me dis
parce que quand on donne des milllions
pitié bon tu vois quand ils travaillent
dans les médias on dirait que vu que tu
fais peut-être plus d'argent parce
qu'ils travaillent dans les médias on
s'attend un comportement de toi
pis mais ça vient avec une pression donc
je me dis avec la ligue nationale que
les griffons des ultras millions surtout
à montréal mais ça vient avec un
comportement mais ça vient aussi avec
une pression extrême n'a pas du
comportement ça ces intouchables
comporte comme un adulte comme un
professionnel un professionnel
même si on donne genre 6 millions de 18
ans ce qui est fort qu'une carte
imaginez-vous de leurs huit semaines yes
400000 qui drape dans votre compte à
chaque est trois semaines un opus les
mauvaises décisions je réprime angolais
a pris des personnes qu'ils aillent au
vote rechercher un planificateur
financier
ils reçoivent beaucoup d'argent c'est
moi je gratis dans tout les restos se
rendent pas une émeute
avec ce que j'ai tout le temps tendance
à être plus patient avec eux mais la
faute de comportement ça j'ai pas de c
si non il n'y a pas de critiques eric
neuf catégories la fin de la pression en
attendant le milieu ne serait plus
j'avais les affiches comme mais la
pression de rondelle frapper si tu le
vois son body language est sur la glace
ma classe et des bottines notre dame
face il ya la tête penchée pis c'est
chose qu'on met beaucoup de pression
mais ça vient avec les caches sur ça
mais c'est un peu la raison pour
laquelle les salaires sont ce qu'ils
sont et les salaires sont ce qu'ils sont
parce que mettons tout âge de travailler
tout le temps une description des
positif un esprit négatif mais le
salaire étant en position par rapport à
qu'est ce qui coince le fait que faut
que tu te comportes en professionnel il
faut que tu performes ben ça qui vaut à
pourquoi le savoir est aussi élevé je
vous pose la question le temps
ton choix tu es un des meilleurs de la
ligue [ __ ] choix entre joueurs
montréal où je voyage un coin perdu
comme caroline tu fais le même montant
d'argent tu t'en vends caroline de
montgueux c'est ce à quoi ce que total a
pensif
je prendrai ça mais c'est ce que je
m'attendrais se disait aussi l'idée qui
pâtit montréal oui j'ai joué à montréal
c'est excitant pitt est une vedette
piste humide c'est la vie la beauté
c'est une vie normale ce qui lui est
arrivé à me sauter une dictée est arrivé
le pilote il y avait une contre
performance
enfin personne il posait une question
sur sa contre performance et rené chez
eux billetech sommes surpris au début de
ne pas avoir besoin de justifier une
contre performance tic mois le temps une
contre-performance ici news high co de
24 heures était la pire personne
rappelle à amener des harnais il y avait
une passe ou ça marchait vraiment moins
bien qui il était une émission de radio
où est ce qu'ils ont fait de jouer
l'animateur ce qu'ils disaient pendant
sa partie puis le dernier le bihan temps
il ya enfin les commentaires qui avait
été dit plus haut le gars est vraiment
comme vraiment rock avec david dernier
puis ça revient près dernier le regard
des faits apprend le stéphane je postais
qui il la regarde fait stéphane tous
était jamais arrivé d'avoir une mauvaise
journée au travail
ce n'était jamais arrivé plein fait ben
oui ça m'arrive à moi aussi
puis toi quand ça t'arrive ya personne
n'est pas suspendue pendant tout le
temps dans l'épicerie qui rit jaune de
tennis marre de toi et jaurès aurait été
changée mais
et même temps il ya des joueurs qui le
méritent pas ça des joueurs dernière le
connais pas fait que je veux pas qu'ils
attendraient ma première entrevue dans
ma vie c'est guillaume latendresse a
ouais tu jouais encore il jouait je
pense qu'ils étaient reclus chez huawei
tabarnak première attelage le temps à la
bac puis la prof a dit madame duflot
myspace indique m enfin un exercice
choisir joie l'ami nationale puis
prépare des questions ok dit prenez pas
trop dur de la tendresse
moi je propose mes questions la journée
que je fais l'entrevue un clip moi je
sais pas jean cours avec elle dans le
bureau puis a dit au parisien de
chercher on va aller très loin et les
affaires en chambre froide on allait
diffuser des signatures des tubes allait
poser des questions à guillaume
latendresse avait tout organisé tout
organe mâle lui cette femme-là changé ma
vie mon jeu dans mes profs les gens
retournent dans les voies mais pas le
temps de madame philly ciel ou madame
dufour madame grès gucht je retourne
tout le temps les vois pas ce que c'est
si c'est pas de roeschwoog chine
j'arrive là-bas j'ai sûrement rappelé
aux juges pour la première question tout
va bien ma deuxième question c'est
est-ce que tu as des superstitions son
agenda il n'ya pas l'europe et de sa
femme voulait déchirer
je sais pas ce que pour mettre tester
owada veut mais guillaume avait dit aux
félicitations j'ai pris en photo avec
lui mais à ma prof me lave est
développée tout que c'est bon la
première sera belle lettre je pense pas
que ça rappelle celle sur parles-tu
reparle après le tuent leurs portes en
entrevue geste non guillaume c'est comme
en dessous il ya comme une gamme g comme
jamais parlé guillaume lapp ya tout les
comme aux gee canadien de ce que les
fans et les cinq six années de guillaume
latendresse à l'époque
- mais ce type soit si on a fait des
événements à s'en rappelle plus de son
nom c'est à contre a+ événement petit on
a créé une relation même chose francis
bouillon même la peau toute cette
génération le moins proche
mais toute l'équipe québécois je suis
plus proche parce que souvent il y en a
qui ont vu commentateurs haïtiens qui
étaient impliqués dans quatre cinq ans
ils font pousser des cris yes
les matchs du canadien on est comme des
geôliers puis après ça avec la classe et
que safran
on se rapproche plus mais si vous voulez
manger l'image de 15 défaites
hugh grant la mangue la gueule saab a
tout perdu ses dents il sans vote dans
le vestiaire janvier avec un avec un
gars qui croque yvelines ça et rembarque
sa glace même punition pour moi un des
top canadien stéphane c'est la teuf le
american history x temps qui cassent les
dents je sais ce que c'est fait formé
d'une bande la gueule de tout péter la
somalie nationale d'une façon où c'est
difficile de chez lui à chaque année
c'est une année de plus sur son cas lui
ce n'est pas celui ci je porte cette
manière il peut plus jouer pendant je ne
sais pas non plus si loin mais droit les
droits elle lui pas joué pendant les
salons marché dans un parc le plus j'ai
rien contre j'aime beaucoup de gens
j'aime beaucoup sa blonde marie laurence
debroux people depuis prendre soin des
enfants puis tout mais pas mais moi dans
un parc c'est lui c'est à gauche à
droite fin et ball
steve bégin et il faut qu'il lance sa
tête soudains d'ego c'est pas une vie
m'a même dit pas l'effacer pas un viol
non si ça et c'est aussi ce que je
trouve fort top c'est que ces galaxies
comme des grinders c'est ce qui donne au
moins dans l'équipe le pea
moi je repassais djoghlal serov moi j'ai
mieux joué la ligue 1 et chapitre bon
faire des buts pas avoir besoin de me
battre pas besoin de frapper personne
qui sait moi faites maison mais tant qu
encore que l'on peut le traiter
effectif et mettons ces entrevues lors
dû commencer j'imagine a déjà intéressé
aux médias puis au domaine du support
afin de mettre tout le temps été
intéressés par les sports d'eau des
sports manger en 6e année j'avais
participé à l étude en amont primaire ah
ouais j'avais j'avais fait une page sur
chaque équipe canadienne
les points forts et les points faibles
bon je vois les moins bons joueurs
avaient rejoint un docu mal puis après
ça je retrouve ce groupe d'âge comme ça
joue au foot puis madame grégoire soit
dans 3 le fait
yo je pense qu'il faut aligner comme du
monde là on va partir rejoindre
l'étudiant puis on voit le match faisait
pas partie chaque mot chose en arctique
et je comparais le canadien une pizza
pepperoni c'est telle personne
musée at il laissé vraiment pas ce que
je voulais puis en plus met d'accord
j'ai mes fautes comme chuck labelle vite
madame irma guerre puis après ça on a
gagné le prix entrepreneuriat québec
parce qu'on voit d'un journal puis on va
d'un journal beaucoup on va d'un coût de
25 sur les métiers
l'idée du projet parce qu'on a gagné le
prix ans à 4 après sa 5e secondaire en
spectacle alterne l'on n'ait pas choisi
de faire le saut dans ce spectacle
québec même si on a fait locales
régionales ont été les meilleurs points
à nîmes il n'a pas été choisi pour le
québec je dis aux phoques foule tout
animé la soirée
j'animais parce que moi se cacha sera la
cape les animateurs étaient pas en font
que j'ai dit les jaunes la journée même
j'étais voilà madame jeudi dans un an
c'est moi qui l'animent so many munster
foule il y avait toujours des spectacles
ce genre d'affaires caussimont des
offres de plus pour noël ce sera noël il
y avait tellement de monde al jean y
avait du monde au premier étage avait
mis des télé parce que notre liquidité
comme joker pilou philippe thibodeau et
puis kevin thériault ils vont juste flip
la place le plomb le fait sécateur et
shine comme les numéros
ça ne méritait même pas pris un certain
michel le fils arrive à dix après tout
bien fait mais à la fin on était à plat
soit par la foule les gens cap vert en
état soit l'heureux qui a fait un
backflip les jeunes filles attal
c'est fou mais l'impression fait ce mode
attaque régional même chaud même
réaction donne comme on fasse sur le
spectacle provincial là on reçoit
l'appel offres fait pas le faire
pourquoi puisque vous avez la musique en
anglais dans vos numéros jeu mais c'est
pas une raison
mais on va changer de président on vous
prend pas et clermont 10 a pris le
téléphone [ __ ] et saint andré mathieu de
laval
la puce a dit mathieu j'ai dit bonjour
madame s'appelle diane jellimann
respecte parce que le prix l'appel de
abrite au complet 1
il appelle pris le téléphone sans
dramaturgie vieillot et j'aimerais qu'on
fasse son show on est au collège le
temps non on va remplir la place on veut
faire un show a débuté par des tentes
bien telle date on vous donne la salle
est la pensait pas qu'on vend des
systèmes 400 c'est la moitié de la salle
dans une 450 pensais pas qu'on va des
lots finalement on s'est rendu à vendre
plus à la fête
auch est fou qu'on vous donne la date on
a fait le chauffe soldats trois grecs
inconnu fendre et mathieu de laval ont
fait du porte à porte
toutes les maisons de laval en fait tout
les gros car si laval fait du porte à
porte aux mains des limiers c'est 13 $
monsieur 6,13 dollars madame ce que
voulaient nous encourage comme c'était
du chocolat elle est un spectacle à la
salle andré-mathieu athlètes deux
semaines avant le choix de la salle est
pleine on sera content que notre peau de
chaud on peut pas faire le même choix
des spectacles parce qu'ils seront des
spectacles seront présents marie luce
qui vous ferait mon beau sapin que les
préposés
taylor comme elles ont commencé à
essayer de patiner par des chauffeurs de
camions coiffard ressources elle n'a
préfet le roi c'est le voit qui sortait
de les connaissant le mot après phil
d'appeler jean thomas jobin un way aussi
là on avait de l'esu plus parce qu'elles
n'ont passé parfois d'argent karam a
envoyé le chèque lé la soirée bat ye'or
j'avais jamais joué autant d'argent sur
un chèque sur une place là j'ai dit je
vais drop sa d'amour route tout ça déjà
le 70 de ce classement mal muti diane
son ex pete a gagné lors de fêtes you
fuck des fans on avait l'argent moi je
pensais c'était cet humoriste je fais
charvet n'allait pas pu se déplacer
andré mathieu le monde de regarder comme
des coachs et huawei
on a fait la cendre et mathieu soldats
on n'a pas encore de l'argent au plus on
avait mis comme des feux d'artifice
machine veste les troisièmes chose faite
maison des arts soldat tu peux ce chalet
des bas mais c'était dit au total
j'arrive à goethe arrivé à l'abreuvoir
c'est mon premier mais mon premier vrai
show de barbe des fêtes où lucho à la
balle qui était bizarre compromis vrai
bord d'un circuit se révèle à brabois
j'arrive je suis le premier sur le pc il
se cogne au moi je vais ouvrir sans
foule arrive là les trois quatre
premiers doubles personnes riz farine
mois 19/09 un jeu contient jusqu'à la
salle andré mathieu oui j'ai fait tri
850 personnes puis vous bande de 50
personnes voulaient parer c'est un gros
ya du siècle c'est pas la même chose de
4 soit aux pros petit show à toi
quelqu'un d'avoir des gens qui sont des
professionnels france puis gros match
est mystérieux penche la tête travail
non pas de simples ipar pa ni sympathie
pour toi maintenant on ne savait pas que
taquiner ses 206 tht qui eux sont venus
ils ont payé jusqu'à souvenirs et
pendant huit minutes c'était paris
s'était fait peur et nex
et sabri digitale avant de retourner la
balle comme il fallait pas leur beau
mais deux s'étaient jamais comme partout
en venant d'autres banques
des fois ça marche des fois ça marche et
pop effet comme l'a fait petit à petit
ça commence à marcher souvent presque
tout le temps partiel le fonds noté le
taf encore là je fais moins de baracoda
du tournage est encore west qui mettons
maintenant on va ce ton site le et
maurice buttin journalistes qui y aller
se cacher dans ce moment les musiques et
moi je leur ai dit m
bell il m'a fait cette lapasset fallait
que je la pop des jedidi moi c'est toi
qui m'a mis dans le problème de faire le
job a opté mon propre c'est mon ego et
les gros ne pas ce point là non mais oui
c'était deux parties si je trouvais
vraiment important moi j'ai étudié en
journalisme de montréal c'est pour moi
c'est vraiment important
mais oui c'est encore importante je
continue à écrire des blagues faciles à
faire des blagues en écho repos juste
les bâches ou moins denses définies tard
j'ai des fois je me réveille tôt le
matin pour tourner fait et c'est des
excuses que je me dois d'en assembler
dans la vie c'est là que je suis mais la
sainteté est super important pour moi
c'est tourner même avant mon équipe
l'iphone
j'ai mon équipe mène c'est sur les deux
jeux le capitaine jeu sakho et vous saku
koivu mais on vient du camp salariés
aient pitié je dois aider tout le monde
essaie de garder le mode positif
et s'il est une bonne personne pouvoir
et des tilles caméraman ya pas
nécessairement une bonne journée hier où
allez-vous sur l'autre tournage je le
quatrième sur mon tournage
ses hobbies tout le monde est content
vie et à chaque journée une journée
différente à chaque journée on running
gag avec sa chaussure fous de ma job
quand c'est mes équipes par moitié que
je veux sur un tournage au tour que je
pense que tout le monde c'est cool mais
quand c'est mon équipe par mouawad
comment je le prends personnel c'est les
robes portées sont chez nous c'est
personnel
magan ma famille pendant trois-quatre
mois piscine saison deux ou trois ou
quatre héroïnes let's go baby moi je
veux le pied droit mais non je m'appelle
l'accord de la veille qui l'avait dit et
si on garde tout la même équipe j'ai dit
oh j'ai besoin de tout le monde qui est
de la saison tout le monde tout le monde
tout le monde
on est tous cas pas de garde et je te
dirai 80 je blesse c'est que justement
tout ça prenne à fait relatif et kendra
fait le show sportif l émission de
renault il ya se sait sous compétence à
casa l émission de renault c'est aussi
la lutte à tobias pas manquer un à
crédit depuis deux ans et demi
j'ai fait la lutte armée crédit
je partis si le jeudi au danemark je
suis revenu le lundi pour pour la lutte
le moral moi je suis c'est la meilleure
job que je pouvais avoir commenté la
lutte
je suis assise puis je trie sur mes
chats un bichon la piste fait de la
peine à personne de balle et jason bay
chaque mois sur installations les
réseaux sociaux les jeux comme gaz s'est
arrangé mais mes athlètes en santé les
personnes qui qui croient que la lutte
et par angers c'est des fois je leur dis
que des fois je les laisse vivre leur
vivement ce soir comme femme mais que tu
le veux voir ma chicha méchaal
essayez de comment je peux dire est
essayé de rendre plausible que le mes
chattes de nos coups de chaise à l'autre
c'est la plus belle chose aux banques
essaient de nous et que l'autre personne
admettent deux doigts d yeu petit comme
oui mais c'est parce qu'elle a le mérite
et là des fois lèche comme j'espère que
dans dix quinze ans je vais écouter
peuvent être comme j'étais de mauvaise
farce c'est perçu par ce qu'il y ait
beaucoup de commentateurs de ces
affaires liquidienne la légende d'aidé
comme des calques et en tant qu'hommes
religieux les fameux gueuler est devenu
une légende à cause de jardin quand le
leti trop de temps à faire ce que
beaucoup d'incidence est comme la lutte
s'est arrangé il ya pas d'incidence en
même temps tu vois quand ils viennent au
centre bell ou comment ces calvino
sandell ils font douze treize mille
personnes qui viennent à la balle et
s'ils étaient pleines et depuis qu'on
fait la lutte avec pat laprade mon
collègue viol les gens viennent me voir
marc fait tout le talent
maintenant tu t'écoutes la lune ils
viennent me voir pitch-in sorte une de
mes les jetons bio il écoute là le 1 2 3
mois jeudi jésus marie joseph le père
richard graille et et j'ai des idées
inside avec presque tous les lutteurs
affecté c'est sur quel thème lutte at
war in inside qu'il soit dernièrement il
ya eu 8 h avec le puits deux ennemis de
plus de 2
me disais à tout le monde c'est magail
pays étaient mes chances de médaille qui
a été gentil ce thème a guère puis le
lundi dernier s'est fait attaquer contre
un autre mais chaque le jeu partie
positif c'est ce petit plus par pendant
trois minutes
mais j'ai dit vous savez quoi laisser
faire j'embarque avec l'autre que les
gens interrogent sur les réseaux sociaux
mais envoyait des messages était comme
comment tu pu laisser un culte à terre
un menu du livre usines à plein des fois
je continue c'est sur mon personnage
mais rarement parce que y'a pas les
messages à son white le truc j'en vois
qui même si c'est une bonne habitude de
prix ne pas regarder les médecins belges
sont obligés après les trois premiers
mois de tva sports
je voulais couette parce que les gens
étaient peut-être avec moi le jeu comme
je vous ai rien vous ne connaissez pas
vous me connaissez pas point vous savez
pas si je suis bon pendant 2 les
affaires de wealth & chips bas c'est
cependant une croix dans un petit peu
délaissé shit le gardez les pour vous
parce que dans ma face tu me le dire
répond quand ils me disent et les
réseaux sociaux
1 pourquoi depuis six mois je savais que
mon chou passé parce que je recevais dit
oui c'est shit les gens à mon équipe
il savait qu'à mons ou pas c'est parce
qu'ils contrôlaient la page ce matin et
chaud à l idée comme ac et le show est
pas recevable c'est chez nous à 4
mondial à québec c'est pas de la cie
souvent je supporte le québec et les
états unis
je dis juste que yahoo il ya des gens
qui méritent de brouillard du tchèque
qui en a pas quatre mais dans ces cas là
ne vraiment beaucoup
la raison koch d'essence parce que je
les ai vécus à une échelle de a pas de
sens et mallarmé date de taza tâche va
en avoir je live tapas que j'accepte ce
mouvement black terme a-2 car l'amendé
est devenu plus gros londres et qui
ressortait des boilles puisque commun
qu'est ce qui s'passe de la boîte de
messages comme ce téléphone bâcle les
gens qui ne s'excuse et non non non non
juste comme un drogué de ville c'est
comme arrête de parler de baccarat
dollar au delà de chatham ont dis pas
que ta vie vaut pas la peine on dis je
prenez deux secondes pour entendre notre
réalité
puis c'est pas juste aux states je ne
dis pas qu'on est d'éviter missiles
comme aux thèses puis des meurtres à
chaque jour mais il ya des chiffres qui
arrivent ici qui sont faux klopp qui
sont institutionnalisés et puis si on
n'en parle jamais on ne pourra jamais
les changer moi je veux jamais pointé du
doigt quelqu'un qui était à 6 me disais
il ya une mauvaise personne de taille si
ce nom 6-6 lundi et mardi qui décide
d'ouvrir ton cap de changer c'est dans
mon équipe ne joue pas de pointer du
doigt parce que bon on en fait c'est
toujours ce qu'on fasse la part des
choses puis ça mon vidéo j'avais dit
fans un 12e sur tout le monde doit avoir
tout le monde qu'ils écoutent takahashi
3,6 tu lèves tu veux connaître la
personne de la conversation et c'est
fini y'a pas de guadeloupe à ce que l on
a parlé d'un simple double ensemble
comme ça peut être les autochtones non
on parle jamais d'eux hôtes chinois
n'ont pas jamais des autochtones dieu
j'ai acheté un mouvement autochtone life
my drug crise mais parce que on parle
jamais d'eux j'ai peut être pas de
caisse avec abrégée de la couette qui
joue pour team canada autochtone qui ça
va sortir éventuellement puis à me
parlait l'appui ggg m newt gémissons
mieux si j'ai rien à dire moi pas moi
ton shit parce que ton chip ici à
montréal tant chez les plus fortement
chez ben oui c'est forte baisse comparé
des chiffres mais cette enquête de
comparer une récession mais en ce moment
tu es plus dans le trouble
toi que moi au canada sow je vais mettre
les bouchées doubles pour forme assuré
de pouvoir aider plus possible parce que
je sais que vous avez notre bac mais les
revendications du mouvement black la
smart on n'a pas posté sur russie s'est
même si c'est pas directement sur eux je
pense que n'importe quelle minorité qui
réclament les plus des garanties
ça a un effet bénéfique sur tout le
monde mais effectivement qu'ils méritent
leur mouvement avec la main parce que je
veux qu'on sait je veux tu es des
autochtones ici le temps des 3 4 puis
que c'est pas un réflexe
ce n'est pas un réflexe d'invités budget
moi et j'ai vu à ma femme j'ai dit
qu'ils d'autochtones que je connais ces
câbles je me suis posé la question tu te
demande pas quelle blague conel on
connaît des blacks mais qui
d'autochtones que je connais un gîte à
je connais belgique par la presse belge
six autres missions à fortes sommes ne
sont pas on le chalet mais forme je dis
oh oh c'est pas fort aux flèches plus
lisible jette
j'ai arrêté de l'est parce que j'ai fait
mes atouts match mais il est où le match
j'ai besoin que toi tu m'expliques le
chip
j'ai hâte de sortir parce que les gens
ils vont vont comprendre que vous les
blacks c'est difficile au hockey mais
les autochtones oh my god est ce que tu
as déjà entendu les témoignages de
jordin tootoo yaya kolo touré lui
naroff anna barnak l'inspecteur tahar
langues nationales pia ster c'est un
excellent joueur mais c'est un top five
puis lui s'est fait le genre tout son
parcours 2006 elle était tout le temps
fois king tubby le guettait com afin la
fin de sa carrière est en dépression
petit de maintenir sur 10 à 10 c'est
plate a dit gay mais sa part des parents
sa part des parents la première fois je
me serais trop cheap and white c'est un
parent j'avais 13 ans oui le paradis
tchèque les noirs c'est le parent c'est
les parents c'est là les basculements de
nos volumes et les parents au hockey
hockey mineur c'est moi je me rappelle
le moment où ce qui j'ai décidé
d'arrêter de jouer mon pari ultra low
profile en été il va jamais dire un mot
plus au club et puis dans les situations
sociales il va souvent être lui et acide
qui dit rien
émettons qui regardera qui venait aux
compétitions natation et à six puis dix
puis dans une game boy qui a amené
l'arbitré le guen peut-être peut-être
midget puis d'avoir 15 ans puis des
forces et la fin de semaine pour gagner
neuf pièces de l'ortie il faut un col
qui veut qu'on joue plus les parents se
lèvent des estrades les se met à crier
après après l'arbitrage est assis sur le
banc mais le regard plein et je veux mon
père qui a amené par la foule qui
eve qui lui-même se l'est puis commence
à crier après l'arrêt plein moi dans ma
tête je me dis non non je me dis non
c'est pas sur tes pieds le contraste
avec la natation ou est-ce que le monde
était vraiment différent où est ce que
je suis tout le monde et comme hey good
job dit félicitations un meilleur temps
petit alors maintenant donner ton effort
maximal petit puis le mot jt je vois ce
pelé ce moment je suis en train
d'essayer de choisir entre les deux
sports tu fais pas qui est non je peux
pas être dans ce climat là oblige c'est
pourquoi c'est pourquoi la natation les
parents sont plus motivés par la ligue
nationale parce quand est ce que ton
pied droit qu'il tu vois le signe de
piastre - si ce soit le signe de piastre
dépensés soit signe de pièces qui ça
peut t'amener soit pas de signes de
piasses sur la natation le nom est pas
le travail au starbucks people sport
c'est très juste de penser que jamais
afin de takhar l'orientation tu arrives
à 0 1 tonne stickers fou au québec le 24
ans avant qu'ils n'arrivent à 0 1 par
ailleurs
moi je te garantis que je peux arriver à
0.2 puis on voit pas le signe de piastre
les gens de natation je suis bonne les
parents football moi je coachais femme
assise une saison cette année sa
quinzième saison
moi je vois les parents foot je vois les
parents au hockey moi je suis blesse au
foot je crache un collège privé collège
des maraudeurs jusqu'à l'âge de battre
les par as his règle est entré autres
waquiez hills
il s'élève élèves oui ça et c'est vers
le bas ensemble il devient de plus en
plus des monges membre mois la commune
fois j'ai vu mon père comme une fois
j'ai vu ma mère est assis prendre son
café à côté de d'autre part à blanc
pendant que je me faisais traiter d'un
wild elle a dit rien parce que la loi
dit parce que cela leur est il là un
groupe black woman qui comprend approuvé
pop
elle a dit rien quand j'habitais sur
l'embarcation la patinoire à seul avec
m'encourager ccc fourre tout cas le
véhicule et faisait ça n'a aucun sens
imaginé tes parents et même scène pour
danser la salle des fêtes
parce qu'au foot on dirait que les
parents sais tu penses que ton govou
seront à la nfl c'est tellement
impossible qui oppose l'équipe des
méfaits lice il n'y a pas la même
culture nfl que si il dit au père il va
jouer à l'université au p 10 il va se
rendre cégep est opérée sera
l'université il ya réussi
je rappelle que c'est fait c'est la fin
des abbesses un bon point qui amène à
petit laissé tranquille mais les aidera
les jeunes qui font sur une pièce de
l'organisme dit mangez moi j'ai tout le
temps dit une différence si moutons
taboth 25 je vois jamais de critiquer
pourquoi parce que c'est pas citer deux
ans après l'expérience de soi pour geely
quand les plus vieux se ferme avicole à
leurs jeunes à des années parce que
j'étais capable d'apprendre
ouais je veux dire tous les maux
d'église que je peux dire
ma belle des fois je sais que les gommes
attendent pas mais des fois t'es comme
si les habitants sur les lignes de côté
tout dépend je voulais voir puis compte
propre ou ré c'est pas taguer
aujourd'hui de l'état son corps mais
s'étend aux kids c'est monsieur
l'arbitré monsieur la 6eme ton erreur
sinon et monsieur l'arbitré a depuis
créé après après avoir établi ce temps
monsieur après avoir établi le respect
wolf a pas de ton problème avec lui sur
le terrain entre eux qui passent de
capitaux c'est un problème par là lui
livrent pas la laddh
mais tu sais comme des règles de ceux ci
étaient qu'on essaie de mettre dans
cette équipe de football c'est drôle à
voir mais liquide commence à comprendre
c'est des combattants monsieur l'arbitré
comme un essai mais monsieur le policier
mois ci messieurs le policier monsieur
madame l'infirmière you fat ces gens-là
nous être dans la ville et on les
positions de pouvoir là on peut tu les
respecter avec monsieur ou madame ça
c'est qu'est ce que j'essaie d'inculquer
clicquot qui est là c'est bon c'est une
bonne nation
je vais avoir toi mon pote sur comment
tu trouves que la nba en ce moment gère
le bloc live made you avec ce qu'ils
font en ce moment donc le plein il ya
plein de trucs qui ont été mis en place
notamment évidemment le gros black light
malheureuse sur le terrain les le
beyoncé qui a fait en collaboration avec
la nba en espèces de 2
d'album graphique qui s'appelle black
est ce qu un whisky matures en promo
avant tout les matchs le nom sur les
devises et je sais que les joueurs de
partager photos le respectez nous telle
une keynes lugentz d'or ouais ça un
homme est un chien du message en créole
on doit lui que dans this le mieux à gré
ouais c'est juste pour être sûr que tout
le monde connaisse comparant les joueurs
après chaque entrevue ou hanche à chaque
entrevue à la plupart redirige la
question ouverture pour pas que ça tombe
dans l'oubli comment tu ben moi je sais
que ça merveilleux moi j'ai rien à dire
sur la nba l'a éloigné mon point là ce
que tu cliques
ce n'est pas de son je comprends que son
problème clairement des cliques pas de
son coût de la ligue nationale donc une
de udraw jésus la ligue nationale je te
dis j'ai pensé pour regarder les matches
quand j'ai vu qu est-ce qui faisait
hockey est le sport le plus réussi ce
que paul selon la sq
ben c'est là ok maintenant j'ai décidé
que celle qui s'est officiellement le
lac il ya plus de et plus de 2 des bols
ça s'est décidé ces dernières semaines
puis si les gens sont malades mais soyez
magpies vous regardez vous dans le
miroir qu'est ce qui n'a ce qu'elle est
avec des flags les fin de l'année ils
ont enlevé 10 millions mais black line 2
sur le terrain commis d'horribles à quoi
ils y ont fait une cérémonie de black
waves et ont poussé le char du seul
blake un havre 1-1 et sur ses malgré lé
fait ils mettent des noeuds coulants
d'install de ces gens là sont fous le
gaillard yves ajac courage il ya une
couleur à son écurie même genre c'est
décalé 100 m c'est terrible après ça on
fait une enquête avec le fbi ipod they
yola phare est là depuis longtemps
sonia perso keysource mot pas de gadgets
on a trouvé que corey lajoie sur mon ami
puis comme il explique bien un core i do
so on n'a jamais vu le nos couleurs
avant aujourd'hui on est jamais remarqué
ligue et l1 depuis longtemps
fois qu'on le voit à ok
l'autre affaire de fraude mais ils ont
tellement été bon dans la sphère du
black les demandeurs puis continue à
être bon que je capable de le dire avec
certaines choses nba
magnus pec à chaque fois j'ai coûtant
une game je sais c'est quoi ce plutôt
aucune aucune chance de manquer cette
chance de marquer de n'importe qui qui
veut se mettre la tête dans le sable si
tu veux regarder un match de basket le
message dans exactement ça c'est pas
forcément f one avec l'eau center il ya
une bonne démonstration avant chaque
course
avant chaque course est froissé bonnet
constructeur russe islam à chaque
concept démonstration sur comment ça se
fait que la ligue nationale qui ont de
plus en plus de black
ils ont eu besoin qu'un black de
l'alliance de verser des alliances il ya
un regroupement de jeunes blacks joueur
de hockey qui veulent revendiquer leurs
droits pour revendiquer le fait que
yocum décider de ce qui se passe puis ça
a pris que lui vient de faire un speech
que lui tend un speech pu qu'apprécier
que lui tout seul mais son genou à terre
comme anglaise
votez pas trop facile pour vous pouvez
pas vous mettre le genou à terre vous
n'êtes pas capable de mettre un écusson
sur le chandail un écusson sur le casque
foccart était un agent non non et non
mais c'est sale c'est tout fait ce but
tout fait ce but ce week end faut un
goût ce qui est faux pittsburgh n'ont eu
lieu dans sa quête pour pittsburgh
c'est écrit comme tout le monde et c'est
pas d'être cupid éviter le message et
c'est pas des qte m c'est ça c'est sûr
que ce parce qu'il voulait faire
attention à leurs fans buzz
oui mais alors que les autres ligues en
fait phoques des styles and haas corse
est le meilleur exemple de oro perdu
plus que la moitié c'est sûr que oui
mais on gagne et moi j'écoutais des
courses il y avait plein de blagues dans
les estrades pour parce que eux ils s'en
foutent dit qu il mettait plein blacks
dans les estrades
à 24 ans il ya fly in pour aller
regarder une course pour aller supporter
je suis des comptes de nascar - ça ira
je suis là j'ai pas manquez pas la
nouvelle fois des banques et une course
de f1 depuis le début de l'année de
puissance je n'avais pas écouté des
affaires depuis
cette année j'ai vu la première le
premier truc de blaquart majidi a
d'ailleurs je vais l'écouter
là je suis battre le chat avec eux j'ai
pas manquer un dimanche pierrot de
madame mais elle est chère nous ont
failli perdre pis si c'est pas de
mathieu d'un bol je te dis je t'ai
padang
je faisais un autre pas de casque la
première game et l
je le voyais sur les crampes gflops ce
podcast de dj's guest pourquoi ses seins
tout le monde le mail et blake lively
mais de tout le monde pour le monde
pourquoi vous êtes nice là on a régi
c'est qu'on est le 3 ou le ils vont
l'écrit le cas où kim faillit même mais
à date du 3 ou bien les premiers matches
entre qu'il ya les premiers j'y reviens
pas encore c'est pas comme si vous aviez
pas eu le temps
mais non c'est pas comme si vous n'aviez
pas vu les eaux on n'est pas comme s'il
n'y avait pas de blague qui essaie de
vous parler puis haguenau qui essaie de
vous parler depuis des semaines que vous
mettez black reitman
mais depuis des semaines depuis des
années par son nom mais je suis capable
de vivre avec la sphère des années je
capable de vivre avec parce que je
capable de comprendre que n'était
peut-être pas sensibilisés à tête et des
histoires de georges laraque lequel il
raconte son passage dans une échelle que
j'étais le seul noir l'année celle qui
se faisait investisseurs s'étaient pas à
l'échelle mondiale à londres l'once est
clair mais même lui tirs revendiqués sur
ces années c'est comme tabarnak me faire
traiter du world tout les jeux toutes
les autos ligue 1 jacques foutu sa glace
me faire comparer à 1,5 à 1 go reja a
tout les jeux par toutes les autres
jours est par la majorité des autres
joueurs a ramené faut faire quelque
chose mais tu vois ça serviès wac
imminent ont cessé leurs pions férié
avec c'est pour ça que je peux pas leur
en vouloir
je leur en veux pas ce qu'ils font rien
mais je vais pas être aussi urgent que
maintenant nomme le truc et livekive
sais lol ça va vous paraître dans un un
hayon on aurait dû mettre blacklight
made j'ai dit oui le fils d'un autre
robe vert retweet l'image d'ali
nationale qui avait dit bravo la ligue
nationale de rester debout pendant
l'hymne national cette montre à quel
point et tu sais pas lui il
comme ça c'est une honte à faire des
connaissances il l'a vu comme ça il lui
a vu l'image puis a fait ça ne s'est pas
problème ahmad le souk et by sonia moi
j'étais tellement fâché guys chatel j'ai
dit on c'est ma ligne mais c'est
décevant
oui parce que je suis pas déçu
chez moi je suis tout le temps je suis
pas les revendicateurs gens qui qui qui
comment je sais moi je suis plus les
bacs qui j'aime avoir des conversations
comprends moi je suis un gars de
conversation puis c'est étudié la fin
des blessés du on va en parler tant
qu'ils ont plus du nom est lié au fait
ligue nationale j'avais le groupe
d'isabelle google daf
en fait je dis guide des foucades et le
temps que vous réglez pas cette affaire
là je parle a plein de joueurs blague la
ligue nationale blain mais on dit tout
ce qu'on demande c'est qu'on voit blake
lively madère les gens vont dire oui
mais on s'en fout que ce soit écrit ou
pas non non parce que tout le monde le
faire tout tout le monde nascar le fait
de le faire c'est pas compliqué là qui
ont essayé d'être qbe mais c'était mieux
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait avec matthew
d'hommes une évolution c'est moi je dois
t'en dit 'tiens évolution dans
l'apprentissage dans la prise de
connaissance de ce que tu fais je serai
pas des lieux avec ça si je vois que de
semaine en semaine de jour en jour de
semaine en semaine 7 1 milliards tu peux
pas changer le comportement complet en
une journée non pas c'est impossible de
le demander si tu perds tu peux demander
une amélioration qui va mener un but
final du conte face tous on est arrivé
on ait la même équipe s'était investi
hier puis qu'ils étaient prêts à prendre
les atteint formés pour apprendre tout
ce qui est tout ce qu'il faut pour
l'être moins
puis finalement light pub au wood
mais si tu mets des affaires de cheval
la face tu fais comme si ce que
l'annoncé faite ce qu'est la critique a
été vraiment intense la critique est
intense mais tu le verras pas la
télévision de la pression la pression et
le parce que témoin si une chose qu'on
s'est rendu compte dernièrement c'est
qu'ils revendiquent ipsi que
parler puis même sur les réseaux sociaux
ça peut faire une bonne différence à
prendre une petite différence que les
gens seraient groupe ensemble parce que
la pression sur les nations est forte
mais je pense qu'ils ont vécue parce que
sinon il n'y aurait pas laissé damba
parler comme il a parlé
ils y ont fait un beau vidéo parcs
doivent être beaux vidéo package avant
la guerre puis on est là parce qu'on met
en avant la gamme canadiens n'ont pas su
aussi sportif un travail exceptionnel
exceptionnel sporting faut je le
mentionne ils font leurs preuves vidéo
package avant de passer la vidéo partie
de lineage 2 vidéos package blackman sur
des coudes pour cent us et des comptes
mettant les commentateurs tout tu sais
on écrit end racism sur la télévision
des valeurs desk de deux commentateurs
au début tu écoutes pas de sens c'est
quoi tu écoutes tu sais pas tu sais pas
tu es ok les posts ici c'est triste et
c'est ce que ça revienne question de
bahreïn 24 ans l'argentin qui savent
qu'ils éprouvent maxiphone statement
vont perdre des décors mais c'est fou
quand même que juste l'idée de dire
enfin statement antiraciste ses papiers
photos de la maison gagner des fans de
one chez d'hobyo un billet seuil ont
fait selon moi le truc moi j'ai pleuré
quand j'ai vu début à une bille et je
vais dire good men quand les filles sont
parties de l'hymne national j'ai dit y
est j'ai dit un cd fixons pas beaucoup
d'argent et en plus à perdre que les
beaunois lebron james ne fera jamais que
sinon ils sont pas coupés les blanches
comme les blacks comme l'espagne tout le
monde y ont quitté pendant l'hymne
national belfort qui use
après ça avant la game ils y ont fait un
speech au micro s'écrie brian taylor
dent lors de chaque joueur
ils sont tournés par l'hymne national
pour montrer c'est tout des petites
choses qu'en fait c'est des gros chose
pour ses fils parce que confort et sport
féminin pour valoriser comme devrait
être valorisée metz a appris que nous
games fasse un steak mais aussi
recrutement a produit la mls comme yes
man est en fait vers l'avant si l'on
fait bien avant ce qui est mis son genou
à 2
viens m'arreter megan rapinoe elle finit
par taper l'afrique
une jeune femme de 15 ans qui tenait le
drapeau et l'hymne national a lui vu
megan à l'émission genou à terre ça
c'est après quand même cap aunis sont
déjà mais on va jamais d'être idiot au
sport féminin
un des billots et celles qui ont fait
c'était la première league à rouvray
c'était la première les gars faudrait
citer les joueuses black live made
dakar 2 sur le terrain partout crise il
faut donner le crédit aux parfums
féminins dénoncent ils savent plus que
nous que le sport masculin qui y ont
plus à perdre baisse ses équipes y ont
pas de fans ne peuvent pas à perdre mais
il faut parler c'est sûr que c'est
l'intersexualité d oppression le t1 et
un imam c'est sûr que tu vis encore plus
accentuée infecté capable d'être
beaucoup plus sensibles à ces choses là
dessus c'est sûr c'est un bain de sang
ce qui se passe là la réaction de la
gestion de ces deux-là de l'année faute
parce que tu leur gestion de cap unique
était lui le lui s'est fait un fils est
un crime
ils ont même été imagine comment le
monde sage nous piquer comme on
compresse écoule mène lui le fait qu en
personne le faisait acte avec tout à
perdre et il ya tous des revues ou ici
ben oui une carrière de plusieurs
millions de dollars était au super bowl
doigts si ble ment possiblement un
champion plusieurs fois des grands
coureurs de l'histoire un des plus
talentueux que athlétique lockheed
il ya fait un stade mais il ya tout
perdu ce que l'aide au stockage à pornic
et et s'est assis pendant l'hymne
national sur un banc il s'est assis sur
un banc qui avait dit c'est peut-être
des suspects folle envers l'armée je
vais tout je vais contacter quelqu'un
qui est dans seul puis on va discuter et
convenir un entend son nom attendre
demain de son genou à terre parce que
c'est un signe de cartons ton ton
coéquipier ou ton soldat est décédé sous
les genoux à table porter hommage dans
le fond ne le protège ses 1 au match
oui c'est un protest mais s'est pas fait
à terme de manque de respect c'est le no
majo personnes décédées par l'adopter
dépolitise activement le il passe sa
carrière moi puis j'ai jamais dit ça à
voix haute je vais le dire à voix haute
life on a un scoop nicole notât note
leur minutes
le brand gt ou à ce moment là j'ai une
bonne question
moi j'aime beaucoup le blog simon j'ai
préféré à ce moment là seulement
question c'est lui qui avait le plus de
pouvoir c'est lui qui a le plus de poids
dans la balance tu as raison le type néo
l'atb la cage madère puis il des fois je
le vois sur twitter ces cités mais
craint collines a mis son genou à terre
sipa rennais était ou à la défense de
lebron james
il a été un des premiers à sortir
publiquement des années après mais c'est
facile se veut non mais je sais pas si
megan rapinoe elle avait tout à perdre
megan rapinoe avait tout à perdre le
futur jonathan mais c'est foot c'est une
image qui était partagé beaucoup
justement durant le gourou du mouvement
si c'était vous ne dites de revendiquer
puis vous dit de faire de façon
pacifique membres on a essayé lui il le
fait
personne n'a écouté tout dire c'est fou
c'est une dépression sont pas capables
de son roi john baird le commissaire est
incapable de son nom encore une fois la
france a pour sa part du top c'est à
fouet le spectre des codes football mais
jerry jones je vous donne c'est que les
honneurs des dallas cowboys lille
ils ne sont pas de casse ok lui ai tout
le temps les médias après chaque guerre
le propriétaire de son propre groupe de
journalistes
il parle tout le temps à chaque jour il
ya un chrono des jo bhi jones qui sa
part le pape n'a pas parlé depuis akena
one on je savais me laisse encore plus
c'est comment le partenariat dit moi je
suis un joueur des cowboys demande est
échangé ces deux suspects refoule
comment le panais auriez dit ça fait mal
comment les types n'est en rien dit
c'est là que tu vois comment la nba sont
en avance puis pourquoi c'est une des
raisons pourquoi c'est la ligue avec la
plus grande expansion bic est le plus de
succès en ce moment pourquoi le
basketball est rendue internationale
grâce à l'ambiance parce qu'ils sont
roque sur ces affaires le bois première
chose que papa vite chef a dit hier
coach des spurs qui gère le coach le en
ce moment le coach parle mec le plus de
quoi être de toute la nba pour sa
première chose qu'il dit
après la première game des spurs il
rentre là il dit weston boones games est
en ce moment vraiment de remettre notre
attention sur la justice pour blanc la
terreur puis la justice sociale c'est le
coach qui dort un homme blanc de 65 ans
s'envole au pyla première affaire qu'ils
disent et s'appuie lui il parle à des
hommes là je passe et écouter le podcast
avec steve que le coach des noms je peux
écouter les golden goal de lui et wyeth
de golden state puis pete carroll le
coach des seahawks hawaï 200 millions un
podcast sa période coach caoutchouc
mentionné sur le ring le le réseau de
bill siemens pire merde que les autres
ont su papa vide justement se couche le
gregg popovich qui ensemble ont parlé
puis on dit en ce moment dont on est
trois hommes blancs d'au dessus de 50
ans pis c'est extrêmement important que
nous on parle sur cette plateforme là
parce qu'il dit en ce moment dans les
gens qui nous écoutent
je suis persuadé qu'à une grande
majorité qui ont besoin d'entendre le
message le plus dur fait que même eux
sont capables de reconnaître qu'ils sont
dans démographie exact 22 sports hommes
blancs faire écouter si vous écoutez
centre-manche vous avez probablement
besoin d'entendre le message on se voit
on va transférer entre ensuite sans
restriction au 31 mai je veux continuer
la conversation dosso sa restriction
fait que s'ils voulaient continuer
conversation là on transfère sur le
podcast sans restriction et baby